you just can't create this kind of
experience unless you shoot it live you
guys excited
cameras in the cockpit underwater even
mounted on a jet
all right here we go
at times there were 27 cameras shooting
simultaneously
we worked with the navy and the top gun
school to formulate how to shoot it
practically because if we're gonna do it
we're gonna fly in the f-18s
this cast went through five months of
flight training led by instructor tom
i started mounting a single engine
airplane to build up their spatial
awareness inside the aircraft oh wow
everybody thought it would be impossible
for actors to really be in the jets
but that's the gift that tom gave us
that by the time we got up there
we could handle it you can't act that
the distortion the face they're pulling
seven and a half eight g's that's
sixteen hundred pounds of force
i am so proud of them and what they've
done and it is heavy duty
what else went into making this movie
authentic
this airplane that you see in the
background that's that's called a p-51
that's a world war ii airplane and
that's mine
it's my plane
yeah tom brought his own plane as for
miles teller he took seven weeks of
piano lessons so he could play great
balls of fire as a tribute to his movie
dad goose goodness
he's an extremely intelligent and
talented pilot geez rooster not that
fast but he has a lot to learn forget
the book trust your instincts he just
naturally just started to bring just
started to bring it and we as we were as
we were developing it and testing it we
do kind of hear makeup tests and spend
time together
uh
and i knew right away just when we were
there that that this is he's he's
rooster rooster was the role glen powell
wanted but when he was offered the role
of hangman instead he originally turned
it down i just don't can't even imagine
what it would feel like to have said no
you know this is a lesson for all of us
don't say no to tom cruise i want to
give them an event that's always my goal
it's kind of simple but
that's what i do
[Music]
you